what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar back at it again to discuss
the latest craziest boruto chapter in
this one we have a new villain and more
information about naruto's fate
so make sure to stay tuned for that if
you do enjoy these boruto chapter
reviews and want to keep them coming
then the best thing you could do is
throw a rasengan
at that like button if you haven't
channel your inner hokage and destroy
that subscribe button as well and this
is crucial hit that notification bell
or you will miss future boruto chapter
reviews and while you wait for the next
chapter review to drop
after this video you can check out my
growing naruto in borto playlist where i
got videos on all the uzumaki otsutsuki
and much more link to that is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all the
cover page is called
bro and it shows boroshiki aka boruto
being taken over by momoshiki
looking pretty fresh the otsutsuki are
hella strong so if boruto somehow learns
to harness this power
without it taking over him as momoshiki
plans to do
the sky's the limit for his potential
power we start off with boroshiki
smiling after taking out sasuke's
renagon
last chapter even ishiki was annoyed by
the trickiness of sasuke's renagon in
the past
so for momoshiki it makes sense to get
rid of it asap although it was
definitely
shocking when we initially saw it happen
in fact the first thing boroshiki says
is that he's blocked sauce case pesky
space-timed in jutsu so that there's no
escape for him now
further emphasizing what we knew to be
true enemies don't like to face the
rinnegan
naruto looks in bad shape but he's still
conscious and kawaki is obviously
freaking out too
momoshiki says that this is the second
time he's emerged
and that it's nice being free last time
was when he took out boro with that
insanely big rasengan that was a super
hype moment but this time unfortunately
momoshiki is using that insane power on
our guys rather than on the enemy i know
it's not the same situation because
momoshiki
is not a tailed beast but i'd love for
down the line if borton momoshiki
could get on the same page and have a
kurama slash
naruto kind of relationship that would
be pretty awesome not gonna lie even if
it's probably never gonna happen but for
now momoshiki is still clearly an
enemy trying to completely take over
boruto's body
and kill the others sasuke notices that
because of momoshiki's special healing
abilities
all of boruto's injuries have been
healed miraculously
including his shattered wrist otsutsuki
powers are truly astounding and straight
up god like in the world of naruto
remember that all the powerful chiha
attributes and uzumaki attributes can
trace their origin back to a single
otsutuki
namely hagoromo aka this age of six
paths
kawaki remembers how boruto wanted to
help him by crushing jigen
he wants borto to snap out of it but
burushiki is solidly
in control right now telling kawaki that
he should be smiling
since ishiki's soul has been completely
destroyed he does say that kawaki's
freedom is fleeting though
seemingly implying that borussia may
kill him soon kawaki is angry but he
doesn't come up with the best insult
here he says shut up
white eye which is hilarious and kind of
offends me on behalf of the hyuga clan
like those eyes are amazing but the
insult scales of khalaki aside
a fight begins with kawaki's mutant
akira-like arm
boroshiki is too skilled though easily
dodging and then putting a kunai
right into kawaki's back right now at
least it appears that he was right when
he told kawaki that there was nothing he
can do
now it's not clear here what boroshiki
is referring to but he notices something
about kawaki's body and
says good it seems the extraction has
progressed quite far
which means it should work end quote
this suggests to me that the extraction
of ishiki from kawaki might not be
complete yet
and we know kawaki does have a karma
later in the time skip we just don't
know exactly how it comes back
since we're still learning about the
otsutsuki and these karma marks as we go
finally sasuke enters the freight to
help out kawaki but with naruto
seemingly
out of commission after using baryon
mode it would seem they're still
hopelessly outmatched you gotta respect
sasuke
though he shrugs off a lost eye and gets
back into action like it's no big deal
now we get that precious info about the
karma and that
even if it vanishes that otutsuki data
still remains
in the body as with boruto the process
was 80 percent complete with kawaki
before the karma was removed but it
still means that his body is almost
wholly otozuki at this point this may
mean enhanced powers which is always a
good thing in naruto
but it also means that boroshiki plans
to use kawaki as an otsutsuki sacrifice
to cultivate a divine tree it seems like
the battle totsuki always wants to plant
planet-destroying trees and eat their
fruit so they can become even stronger
it's funny because even if ishiki is
gone
borushiki is pretty much just picking up
where he left off with his plan
kawaki is sick of people using them as
objects or more accurately sacrificial
pawns in their plans but these ototsuki
use their
powers to get what they want so if you
want to resist you gotta beat them you
gotta become stronger or at least
outsmart them i do like the double-edged
sword nature of the ottutsuki and the
karma
clearly people can be turned into
sacrifices for the needs of the
otsutsuki but
they also get huge power boosts and
those power boosts can seemingly stay
even if the karma gets extracted so
that's pretty cool
not gonna lie as kawaki is forming his
arm
into a blade for battle we jump to
naruto who is seriously in bad
shape understandably so after all of
kurama's warnings
about using baryon mode i do want to
hear more from that giant fox that we
love
but for now we just get naruto
acknowledging his
body feels heavy and that that isn't
good before he passes out
the fight continues and interestingly
enough sasuke notices that boroshiki
doesn't absorb an attack
he should have easily been able to
absorb burushiki
asks him if he intends to kill his
favorite student which is another
dimension to this battle
not only are they up against ottotsuki
they don't really want to kill boruto
for obvious reasons while momoshiki
doesn't care if he kills sasuke or
kawaki he can fight without holding back
to his heart's content but significantly
enough
he has gotten serious sasuke has wiped a
smile off his face
so since ninjutsu seems to work even
though it usually doesn't against
otutsuki
sasuke brings back a fan favorite move
amaterasu a very
op jutsu that stopped being as useful
when it stopped having any effect on the
otsutsuki villains
although sasuke obviously doesn't want
to kill boruto he did promise his
student that he would kill him if he had
to so that boruto didn't have to worry
about killing innocent people and sasuke
decides to live by that promise
because he is his teacher pretty epic
moment but boroshiki dodges amaterasu
simply enough with a doppelganger shield
it's really nice to see ninjutsu playing
an important role in the battle here
because you can't deny there are such
good ninjutsu moves
and watching ninjutsu battles is hella
fun finally kawaki and sasuke noticed
that something is wrong with naruto
sasuke knows that it's bad and must be a
side effect of baryon mode but he also
knows they can't do anything for him
until they stop urushiki sasuke points
out that boroshiki can dip
at any point with time-space ninjutsu
but he hasn't been
leaving because he wants kawaki for the
tree they gotta get boruto back to
normal
or they won't have a way to return to
the village it's interesting stuff as
sasuke concludes that losing too much
chakra leads to momoshiki taking over
so when another person may die momoshiki
just takes borto's place
meaning between the two of them there is
so much chakra to be had
but sasuke also thinks that if they give
more chakra to boruto's body
his will will become stronger and he'll
be able to take back control
if i was borushiki i might just dip
somewhere else and leave them trapped
here at this point i mean
yeah he can get stronger with kawaki and
another chakra fruit but if these three
are out of the picture he won't have
anyone who can really challenge him when
the karma is completely matured
but yeah sasuke comes to a pretty
fascinating conclusion
that boroshiki isn't using karma to
absorb their attacks because that might
refill boruto's chakra and revive him
even though naruto
clearly surpassed sasuke power-wise with
baryon mode
it's really cool to see sasuke being so
useful i love the fact that they're
foregrounding strategy and deductive
reasoning skills
rather than just brute strength
momoshiki notices that sasuke is
dangerous at this point
and decides to bring quote unquote that
out and by
that it ends up being boruto's vanishing
rasengan and it badly hurts sasuke again
i really like the idea of the vanishing
rasengan
and how boruto's failure to get it right
at first led to him figuring out his own
cool
and very useful version of it but now
momoshiki is using it against his
friends
we get a flashback of when kawaki
rebuilt the pottery he broke
that was an important moment for
kawaki's character development but
specifically for the development of the
bromance between
boruto and kawaki as burushiki kicks him
around
kawaki remembers when boruto said kawaki
is too important for him to leave him
behind and
called him bro did you hear that they
just said the title of the chapter
bro here clearly refers to their
bromance and bond and how boruto offered
him friendship
when he had the belief that no one cared
about him and no one would accept him
kawaki surrounds himself in
fire to the point where he's burning
himself because he's a very valuable
piece for momoshiki
he can't let him die and so he uses the
karma to absorb the fire ninjutsu
that's how much kawaki has come to
respect and care about boruto
he's willing to risk sacrificing his own
life to free boruto from momoshiki's
control
boroshiki takes the bait and a burned
and injured kawaki falls down
boroshiki realizes that after absorbing
that chakra he's gotta act
quick because boruto is about to wake up
just as boroshiki is going to use
space-time ninjutsu to transport kawaki
he stops and we find out that boruto is
now awake and he tells momoshiki that
that's enough
it's funny how chill he is about it he
doesn't scream or freak out at momoshiki
or anything just
calmly lets him know that it's enough
then when momoshiki refuses to just
peace out
boruto takes the otsutsuki horn on his
head and breaks it
and that is enough to make momoshiki go
back to sleep
boruto collapses next to kawaki and at
this point the bromance is going
so strong i'm so curious about how these
two will drift apart during the time
skip because right now
as the title suggests they are as close
as brothers
willing to risk their own lies for each
other crazy to think that kawaki
will go from risking his life to wake up
boruto to fighting against him and
seemingly becoming the villain of the
series
let me know why you think he'll turn
against boruto if you have any
theories in the comments i'd love to
read them in a hilarious and not gonna
lie
heartwarming moment burto apologizes for
causing trouble and kawaki
says back at you stupid bro so he has
that bit of a tsundere
edge that vegeta never loses in dragon
ball z but he still called him bro
symbolically fully accepting boruto's
offer of friendship and even brotherhood
sasuke glad they survived remembers
naruto and goes to check on him he is
clearly concerned and says
no way as he examines naruto's seemingly
lifeless body
now that's the chapter the end of it and
obviously it's a cliffhanger
next chapter we'll find out more about
the price that naruto paid
for using the op mode he did with
kishimoto back in the driver's seat i
think naruto will definitely survive
but this may take him out of commission
for a good while and he may be useless
for some upcoming battles
obviously based on this chapter people
have reason to believe that naruto
could be gone forever but i think that's
just to build the suspense for the next
chapter i actually think that the fact
that kishimoto took over the berto manga
now
means that naruto and sasuke might
actually have more chances to shine
than they would have had otherwise but
yeah that's it for this
chapter let me know what you thought
about it i liked it a lot with the
bromance moments and with the deductive
reasoning of sasuke and with kawaki's
self-sacrificial hail mary strategy
i also can't wait to learn more about
naruto's condition in the next chapter
if you did enjoy this review and want to
keep them coming then the best thing to
do is smash that like button with no
mercy
strike first strike hard no mercy if you
haven't channeled your
inner hokage and be sure to subscribe
and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future boruto
videos and
while you wait for the next exciting
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my growing naruto and boruto
playlist where i got videos on all of
those umaki ototsuki
hokage all the other kage and much
much more link to that is in the
description and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you